i know nick really likes incorporating
fruit into this food he always likes
when i make fruity relishes or fruity
salsa i dare you to try to find food
this good in a restaurant
[Music]
[Applause]
hey i'm crystal and this is my friend
sam i'm a celebrity personal chef and
this week i am going to be cooking all
of crystal's meals i'm really excited
i'm really excited i think you're gonna
love the food
let's do it so we are behind the scenes
in the tasty kitchen watching what
they're making if you've ever taken the
time to make an amazing recipe and you
call it it step by step you got the
highest quality ingredients you've
cleaned this takes like six hours so
people aren't eating this elaborately
because of the time commitment who are
some of your biggest clients two chains
nick jonas i got to work with boogie
cousins when he was injured last year my
first job in the food industry was being
ludacris's personal chef it's glamorous
but it's also a lot of work so you
mentioned the menu that you prepared for
can you tell me about it the menu is
super bright and vibrant and nourishing
there's no specific dietary restrictions
however it tends to be very low on dairy
and gluten and tends to be really high
on vegetables lots of herbs a lot of my
clients don't have super strict
restrictions it's more just giving
healthy wholesome meals that are lower
in carbs and higher in lean protein
when you're cooking for your clients do
you ever worry about calories at all
some of them like for the nba players
it's definitely a lot of focus on macros
so i'll actually weigh everything out
and measure how much carbs how much
protein
the more i watch them cook
the more
i drool and get really excited for the
week to come i keep getting excited over
the dishes that they're making
and thinking this is the one i'm most
excited for and then the next plate
comes out and i'm like no no this is the
one that i'm most excited for and then
the next plate comes out and that's the
one that i'm most excited for
it's been a lot of that
[Music]
so the favorite dish today from everyone
seems to be this
gorgeous vegan burrito that i actually
it was beautifully plated and then i
knocked it over
it is day one meal one and i'm super
excited because i'm actually on set
today taking a little lunch break this
is like super convenient because sam
actually even wrote on here the days to
eat everything so that it would be at
its best and also like that i should eat
this cold versus heating it up oh yeah
look at that here we go
first bite
hmm
that was really really good it's very
like fresh
i could get used to this
and actually i have like really rosy
cheeks if you can't tell
and i'm kind of wondering if eating
really really clean for the next week is
gonna help that at all i'm not really
sure but if it does i might have to hire
her full-time
so it's night one i just got home it's
about
8 20 p.m
i'm pretty tired but i actually have to
leave in a few minutes so i'm finding it
really convenient that i have this super
amazing looking dish already ready to go
for me tonight is persian today with
salmon and a bunch of beautiful veggies
this isn't something i normally probably
would have had in my fridge but i'm
really excited to try this oh there it
is she's beautiful
[Music]
now i can just finish this and go to my
appointment
so i have about 20 minutes before i have
to go to my next meeting not a whole lot
of time to eat lunch but it's making it
really convenient that i already have
this really healthy lunch prepared today
is this really gorgeous vegan burrito
with a bunch of really gorgeous
vegetables in it so i can just pop this
in the microwave for a few minutes
then i'm on my way it's wednesday we're
halfway through the week and one thing
that i've already really noticed is how
much more energy i have than usual these
past couple of weeks have been really
busy both personally and professionally
but the food that i've eaten for the
past few days feels like it's actually
helping me keep up with everything every
dish is so
well balanced and so nutritious that it
actually feels like fuel for my body i
never feel weighted down afterwards i
never feel sluggish and overall i just
have so much more energy it's making me
realize i probably have not been eating
healthy enough
for a while
[Applause]
so we are here
one more time in the tasty kitchen to
finish our meal prep for the week
normally sam actually cooks for her
clients every single day but i didn't
want to take up all of her time she's a
very very busy woman so we're splitting
it up into two days and let's see what
she's cooking today a lot of people have
this perception that all my clients are
requesting what they want and they're
thinking about their meals but most of
my clients don't request much they don't
really
think about their food that's part of
the benefit of having a private chef is
that you don't have to worry about your
food i'm gonna take care of that so i
have one last meal that i'm eating which
i'm eating here in the kitchen as sam
prepares the rest of my meals for the
week
and it is this
vegan pad thai with mung bean noodles
it's so colorful it looks really really
delicious and she just informed me that
tonight two chains is eating the same
dinner i feel like i'm eating dinner
with two cheeses right now you're gonna
turn into a gangster
i don't get nervous to work with any
celebrities now that i know them i feel
more proud of them i feel like invested
in their success i know that they're
just people and i've worked with enough
celebrities by now to know that they're
normal human beings priyanka does have a
salad every day for lunch or a grain
bowl every single day so sometimes when
i'm like running out of ideas i'm like
okay a different type of lettuce or she
usually has a chicken salad
i'm getting so spoiled right now
it looks so good
[Music]
what are you having for lunch i am
having a
frozen meal
it doesn't even compare to your lunch
i have a frozen lunch and you have a
farmer's market celebrity chef created
lunch
[Music]
[Music]
if i have learned anything this week
it's that when you have someone
preparing all of your meals for you you
get so much more done
like much needed haircuts but seriously
i think the biggest thing i learned is
that i was totally wrong i had this idea
that celebrities hire personal chefs
because they can i really i really just
sort of thought that it was mostly about
the convenience but after this week i
actually see it as more of an investment
that hiring a chef like sam is more
about making an investment into your own
well-being because you have someone
there who's supporting your goals and
literally fueling you to be able to go
out and be the best version of yourself
that you can be and i am totally aware
that hiring a personal chef is not
realistic for the average person it's
certainly not realistic for me but it
has inspired me to
find little ways to make those
investments in myself and and i think
it's really inspired me to just be more
aware of what i'm choosing to put in my
body and while i've been at home eating
meal prepped versions of these dishes i
know that nick and priyanka are on a
yacht in miami with sam there making
everything fresh for them hopefully one
day i can afford
that kind of investment in myself
[Applause]
[Music]
you